hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history this is
just going to be a quick one
as i've said many times before facebook
now meta is the company that everyone
loves to hate
with that in mind it's easy to see why
the events of yesterday came with such
great joy to a lot of people metta's
market cap fell by 26 in one day erasing
240 billion dollars of value 25 in one
day
this was the biggest single day market
cap drop in history for a u.s publicly
traded company zuckerberg personally
lost 29 billion dollars in the collapse
so what caused it and what does this
signal for the company
you are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
so why did the stock fall so much
well simply put the facebook platform is
losing popularity
back in 2018 younger americans and
europeans began to leave the platform in
droves
back then that was still okay for
facebook's bottom line because the
developing market uptake was growing at
a much faster rate than western markets
were leaving
in an earnings report yesterday the
company stated that for the first time
in its history the facebook social
network platform was losing daily users
overall
the facebook platform's indian african
and latin american markets are now
bleeding users the platform may have
reached peak saturation
young people in developing markets now
go straight to tick tock and in western
markets facebook is now seemingly a
destination for old people and mother's
groups everyone else mainly uses it for
messenger groups and events the main
facebook wall where most of the
advertising takes place isn't exactly
why people log on anymore
apple's move to make ad tracking more
difficult has also hurt facebook's
bottom line the facebook business model
is advertising driven after all
in short meta wasn't going to be making
as much money from facebook as they
forecast
this news surprised the markets and if
you know anything about trading markets
absolutely hate surprises and from there
we saw the biggest wipeout in history
will this truly be the future for
facebook look it's obviously a pivotal
point for for facebook here and the
question is what happens over the next
few years does it recover and is it able
to pivot into a metaverse first company
is it able to compete with tick tock is
it able to actually lean into video the
way mark zuckerberg wants it to or does
the stock language for the next 15 years
like we saw with microsoft after 2000.
it is rare when you find
so many people getting the story so
wrong going into a print i mean if you
consider the 52 analysts on wall street
who cover the stock 42 of them 42 of the
52 have either buys or or market
outperform ratings on the stock that's
how offsides the street is on the story
at this point in terms of in terms of
this print and the guy tim
facebook losing popularity isn't the
only reason for the fall the whole meta
company is going through a lot of
controversy as we discussed in other
cold fusion episodes there's been major
pressures on meta from regulators and
other government bodies after the harm
that instagram and facebook causes the
teens was exposed over and over again by
various whistleblowers
to add to this the metaverse ventures
have already lost the company 8.3
billion dollars and yesterday it was
revealed the oculus quest headset had
lost 3.3 billion dollars in one quarter
despite revenues reaching 900 million
it's likely that investors would like to
see some results from a venture into the
metaverse sooner rather than later
and it's not like there's no money to be
made
real estate sales in the metaverse
exceeded 500 million last year and it's
expected to double this year to succeed
here meta needs a big slice of the
growing pie
in addition to this growth and risk
stocks may have had their time in the
sun
overall the us economy isn't looking too
great
the country just crossed 30 trillion
dollars in debt and may dip into
recession with the atlanta fed
predicting gdp growth next quarter of
0.1 percent
inflation is rising to record highs
70 percent of gdp last quarter was
companies simply hoarding stock
inventory in fears of inflation
people are quitting their jobs on mass
and interest rates are rising
many investors are asking themselves
does this seem like a great time to be
putting my money in speculative tech
stock place for now the answer may still
well be yes but in a couple of years
investors may look elsewhere for safer
returns
so is this the end of metal
hardly karen i'll go to you first is
down 22 percent warranted it seems a
little overdone to me but you know we
talk about the three-day rule all the
time and certainly i think you know let
the shakeout other meta sub-brands like
whatsapp and instagram are still adding
users meta also plans to focus on their
short video format reels to bring in
more users and generate revenue
this recent crash of meta was most
likely just a stock market overreaction
and the stock will probably bounce back
in no time but if the company keeps on
missing earnings targets things may play
out differently after all just back in
june of last year meta was worth one
trillion dollars and now it's down 35
percent but ultimately it's way too
early to tell what this could mean
so what do you guys think about this
do you see this as just a blip in the
road or do you think that this might be
something bigger a sign of things to
come for meta i do think that this crash
being the biggest single day value loss
in history might tell us something
let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below if you want to
discuss this in more detail or suggest a
future video head on over to the cold
fusion discord if you want to listen to
the podcast versions of these videos
they're now available on spotify and
other streaming platforms so thanks for
watching
my name is digogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll see you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's me thinking